لا مكان للمبادئ امام مصالح الوطن اما
الخلافات السياسيه فهي مصطلحات ضبابيه
وجدت اساسا لتزول بمشيئه المصالح
تلك فلسفه اردوغان العابره للسنوات وهي
تتجلى في برامج حكمه
الغايه محاربه المنظمه الكرديه شتاء موسكو
لم يعد الحياه لعلاقات ماتت ودفنها
النسيان بل ما هذا الطريق لقاء انقره
ودمشق على اعلى مستوى اما موسكو
فلم يبلغ نصرها الدبلوماسيون نشوته الا
بطرد واشنطن من شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
الى الاجتماع بين وزير الدفاع الحكومه
التركيه والسوريه وبيرعايه الروسيه
اتفقت مصالح الجميع بعد اللقاء الاول او
حتى قبله قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه لم يذكرها
البيان بالاسم الا ان اللقاء لم يعقد الا
على شرفها
اتفاق للمصالحه في موسكو اما اكراد سوريا
فقد اعتبروه قرعا لطبول الحرب الخطر بات
يحيط من كل الجهات ومحاربه داعش لم تعد
اولويه
التنظيم الارهابي بدوره يحاول العوده من
تحتها باءه المصالحه التركيه السوريه
تحرير عناصره في سجون قصد اولى من التمدد
ما كانت تعتبره قوات قصد ورقه تفاوض باتت
قنبله موقوته
هجمات التنظيم لم تعود انهزميه المرصد
السوري اعلن مقتل عمال شركه نفط شرق
البلاد
التنظيم لم يتبنى الهجوم الا ان المرصد
اتهمه دون غيره ساعات بعدها قوه قصد تعلن
اعتقال 52 عنصرا من داعش مكافحه التنظيم
لم تعد اولويه الجميع
في لقاء لم يحضره الاكراد